should men get involved in household
chores I'm going to start off
with a brother Matthew inshallah so
isn't it also her dead duty to listen to
us as men to be obedient to us so do the
damn dishes man cook my dinner man
what's this long change you know what I
mean she is taking value away from me
well she's not she is
firstly
as a man it is your duty islamically to
provide it's like a woman coming to me
and saying like you said earlier like
she up like you know you've got to
protect me if a man calls me a name on
the street exactly exactly
if I'm the soul bread winner yes okay
and my wife's at home but lifting a
finger I don't even want to know where
the soul is for example if a woman has
now had a baby yeah and you are working
40 hours a week would you not help your
wife around the house she's like can you
please help me yes I will say to her of
course I'll do the dishes by the way you
got the rent this week you're taking
them okay okay furthermore if my 40
hours that I work per week covers
everything in the household okay and you
want to work not only will I not be
involved in the household chores I will
expect you to contribute towards the
household bills homeless humility is
upon you from Allah yes my duty no no
because in Islam as a woman we have
rights and if you want your house clean
hire me a mate
I just can't see myself debating the
woman that I've met and I've now married
her and we're sitting down in the house
after I've worked my ass off and I'm
debating this woman can you please
please like this is why look I'm be
honest that's the reason I was double
minded about inviting you let me be very
honest here we're mentally okay I agree
with sister yeah she said that you
should marry them that you should hire a
maid if you want me to clean I agree
I'll hire the maid and I'll marry the
maid
um
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another episode of The Bitter
truth if you want to be among the panel
please get in contact by The Bitter
truth show at gmail.com if you want to
ask us a question you're going through
something in your marriage a marriage
crisis whatever it may be you're looking
to get married you want to ask a
question we can maybe touch up on it
give you some Nasir
um to the limits that we have uh please
use that email inshallah
um today's topic is uh should men help
in household tools
um and we're going to see how that goes
and we might even add another Topic in
there which is should it be 50 50 look
so when it comes to a contribution
um be it the household chores or even
providing
um so the bit of puzzles as you guys
know which is that if you disagree with
something assistance
if you disagree you just press the
buzzer the person who's speaking just
finish their sentence and you have one
and a half minutes to say what you want
to say that's what the bitter buzzers
are for but make sure you press it
because bitter something bitter's coming
out your mouth inshallah but obviously
respectfully not in that way yeah that's
it so let's oh open it up inshallah the
discussion should men get involved in
household chores I'm going to start off
with a brother Matthew inshallah so do
you have one and a half minutes uh one
second just hearing the should just
hearing you say should men yeah my arm
just went okay couldn't help it bro even
though it's coming from my brother
Marshall even it was a question I was
asking so okay you got one and a half
minutes go that's it I said it bro oh is
that yeah same more time okay that was
finished two seconds so you you are
totally against it
[Music]
look
we live in a Time in the West where the
average household requires two incomes
okay although we would love for the man
to be the soul Breadwinner and for the
woman to be at home and so on the
reality is especially in this
hyperinflationary environment that we
live in here in the west that most
people need two incomes to run the house
so at a minimum the guy's gonna be
working full-time maybe a bit extra and
his wife's going to be working part-time
whilst doing something the figuring
something out if she is contributing
meaningfully towards the the household
expenditures then it's not unreasonable
for her to expect her husband to involve
himself in some type of choice
if it was I I don't think I would ever
do this but
I I I've looked I've watched some of
your videos there's things that I
disagreed with there are things that I
agree with a lot that's one of the
reasons I invited you to the shop
because at the end I was double-minded
because I know there's a lot of like
controversy around yourself there's
things that you've said there's things
that you've taken back as well you know
which which I admire
um when you discuss about certain
individuals you're very careful to not
back by them so there's certain
characters that I've seen in you where I
thought you know what yes there's a
controversy there's there's things I
don't agree with you but there were
certain quizzes Which I admired and I
thought you know I won't understand you
better that's why I invited you here now
you said some stuff which I haven't
heard the first time I've heard which
I'm very like flabbergasted yeah um is
that you you've actually and please
forgive me I might have there might be
in a video if you've addressed I haven't
seen it yet
that you said that it depends so you're
given some context because usually Your
Role no the men but now you're saying
basically if that you've acknowledged
that
um there's both parties have to work
um so if I'm not mistaken is saying that
the husband should get involved in
household chores and we're talking about
washing the dishes hoovering uh putting
up the uh the clothes
just just understand yeah so um I'm
going to finish one and a half minute
early but because it's the first time
please correct have you said this before
is this the first time is this Like A
New Perspective let's put it let me give
you an example okay
if you have you have average Abdullah
he's working 40 hours a week average
Abdullah he requires his wife her name
is Bushra basic Bushra she is also
working 40 hours a week both of them are
coming home after 40 Hour Work Week
tired just as tired as each other he's
doing whatever he's doing and she's
doing whatever she's doing okay he wants
to come home and relax understandable
but guess what she's also worked 40
hours as well she wants to come home and
relax now if she mashallah wants to take
that all on on her own shoulders so be
it but it's not unreasonable for her to
expect him to pitch in if they have both
done two 40-hour work weeks are you with
me yeah she's refreshing do you
understand have you look what have you
always had this or is it something
that's it's just logical if nothing
before you've been quite Raw it's like
you will get out of me I am the prisoner
to the uh like the animal say I'm I'm
not an island I am the prisoner of the
questioner whether you asked me I will
answer accordingly but I'm providing
context here now if I'm the soul bread
winner yes okay and my wife's at home
but why ain't lifting a finger I don't
even want to know where the soul is
I'm not with I'm not lifting one finger
alhamdulillah Allah bless me with wives
that don't require me to lift the finger
but if I am pitching in and she is
pitching in as well it's unreasonable
for me to also expect her to do now
another part-time shift at home whilst
I'm chilling okay so let me get this in
if I'm correct so if your wife is
working and it's all you and she says to
Matty can you wash up the dishes hold on
and contributing that salary towards the
household now we have to make another
distinction here the distinction here is
okay I'm working 40 hours you're working
40 hours but my 40 hours is paying for
everything in the house and your 40
hours is going on your Mac Foundation
I'm not lifting one finger yeah do you
understand furthermore if my 40 hours
that I work per week covers everything
in the household okay and you want to
work
not only will I not be involved in the
household chores I will expect you to
contribute towards the household bills
well rewind again again say it one more
time yeah
if I'm what if I'm working full time yep
and I'm covering everything expense wise
A to Z yep and my wife wants to work yes
which you wouldn't but whatever okay
let's just use it happen let's go
example okay and she's walking yeah okay
do you want to work no problem guess
what you're paying half the bills why
why good question because I'm gonna be
done a video about my video where you
where I said that if for example if my
wife is a multi-millionaire she is not
paying for anything and then you refer
to I understand where it was coming from
like I don't know if you use the word
simp but you said basically that you
disagreed with it okay so let me provide
context
if I'm working and it's enough for the
house yep now my wife is also going out
to work and she is taking value away
from me well she's not she is
[Music]
firstly
as a man
it is your duty islamically to provide
for the woman as an a manner you have
taken her as a wife so it is your
responsibility regardless of whether she
works or not to take care of her you
went to her father you asked for her
hand and you have said I'm going to look
after your daughter before she came to
you she was working right and her dad
was taking care of her her bills and
everything and now you have taken that
responsibility and she's working and you
expect her to pay half of the bills then
for example if a woman has now had a
baby yeah and you are working 40 hours a
week would you not help your wife around
the house pick up things she cannot bend
you know she just had a baby it is
as a woman in Islam from what I know it
isn't our duty it's not by force you
don't marry us to be slaves you marry us
for a company and to enjoy us as a woman
but it's not you do the chores and I
make the money and if if you want me to
help with the chores then
isn't it also her their duty to listen
to us as men to be obedient to us so do
the damn dishes man cook my dinner man
what's this life change you know what I
mean listen if I'm going to work I'm
waking up yeah I'm going to work here
for nine eight ten hours how many hours
a day that I'm working I come home yeah
and I'm providing like Matthew said
rightfully there is contact for this as
well if I'm providing everything if you
don't need to lift a finger yeah
like what you've been doing during the
rest of your day for this time we've
been sitting your hands watching the
paint dry do I mean I'm sure we can come
up with some sort of circumstance where
yeah I would probably help out and I
would be compassionate enough to help
out if you're giving birth to my babies
I won't be like sorry love you haven't
done the dishes you know I mean I'm
gonna go do the dishes and help you out
I understand that you know what I mean
but you're picking exceptions yeah to
try and disprove the rule which is it's
just like nah and I know I know I've
known sisters they love to bring up that
that Hadith where the Prophet peace be
upon him he helped with some of the
truth how many wives did the prophet
peace upon them have
um about nine did you go to each of
their house cleaning up the yards every
single day but we don't expect
you've got 15 seconds okay so it's like
this is unreasonable you're you're
nitpicking little hadiths and things
like that to back your point maybe not
you personally that's not personal shot
but this is what I just hear all the
time do you know what I'm saying let's
rewind let's rewind inshallah so the
your initial point was your your it was
a two-pronged question the first first
point was with regards to your the man's
responsibility is to provide for the
household and then the second part was
what if she's giving birth so we'll
address both issues
you expect me to work
let's make it different
my wife expects me to work provide and
so on and so forth normality right okay
if a man is in a privileged position
which unfortunately is a privilege today
to be able to sustain a household and a
family on one salary that's a privilege
because the reality is most people need
two incomes so you're in that privileged
position excellent I expect a privilege
in return
the privilege I am offering you is to
stay at home where you want to be in the
first place
the privilege I expect back is a relaxed
wife who hasn't been obeying her master
in the workplace taking orders from her
master over there no she's at home and
she has the food ready for me and the
house is tidy and everything's cool
that's the valley it's an exchange of
value so if I am in this privileged
position to be able to take care of a
woman on her own and she wants to work
in my case personally it's not going to
happen but if a man allows this then it
it is within his right for him to expect
her to contribute towards the household
bills because she is taking value from
him well if she's not though okay she is
and somewhere you're coming from I agree
with a lot of stuff you're saying what
if she's not because something to say we
discussed this like yeah we can be super
sisters I'm like well that's amazing um
so they can like we can do that and work
if they can do that if they're not um
transgressing against your rights would
you are you islamically bound to ask for
that no not put islamically okay I'm not
saying Islamic you're bound to but
Islamic issue don't need to work in the
first place because I'm patterning up
Affairs do you understand this is
something she wants to do yeah if the
husband doesn't want it to work you're
right islamically in this perspective
islamically the husband has a right to
say that you are not allowed to work
exactly but 100 but you're saying for
example that if she um is working uh you
will take a cut off that like I don't
know if the 100 I don't know if that's
islamically correct but number two if
for example you're saying if she is has
a part-time job argument ticket which is
very like rare but Devil's Advocate yeah
if she's not violating your rights do
you have a right to would you still
expect to take so let's address this in
two ways first of all let's spend it on
a Mac I thought this was just me until I
started talking about other men online
crap it's not just me a man just likes
to know his wife's at home yeah 100 even
when I'm at home yes I like knowing my
wife is there even she's cooked she's
cleaned yes everybody
talk to me you know what I do about I
say to my wife I call it it's not what
you want from us come sit next to me bro
that's it just come sit next to me you
know what bro your presence is fine I
understand it's just like
yes so she's done everything you think
logically there's nothing to do no I
just like you being here
I know I just want you to be here but
you're not even talking to me I know I
just want you to be here interesting so
if you're going to the workplace and
that value is taken away from me now and
let me give you a story there's some a
situation like that was not too long ago
after I can't give too many details this
one sister she decided 10 years before
divorcing her husband that she wanted to
divorce her husband her husband
mashallah was very high yeah a woman
like that they plan ahead yeah the
divorce happened a long time ago he's
very high earning individual in a
professional field and he was taking
care of the household completely and he
was of the mindset that I should take
care of the household completely yeah
and my wife can work and her money is
her money but you know she lived 10
years he saved the money bro well I
think I heard you mentioned that she
saved money she saved money yeah so she
could bounce okay okay so so okay okay
one second why is that okay let me put
it like this go on islamically please
tell me or bring me an Evidence why that
is wrong because What's Happening Here
is the following I'm tying my camera
what's my how much time I come number
one I'm giving her Islamic rights if
she's plotting behind me yeah look I
cannot violate those rights because you
know why she's doing something that
she's going to be sinful for she's going
to be doing planning they should
plotting against me that's fine what are
you doing under their judgment there but
I know when I stand in front of Allah is
going to say did you give her rights
Allah gave her rights did you violate
the rights yes you're in trouble so I
would say I know where you're coming
from and men should be smart but not at
the cost of going against the Sharia
this is why it's so beautiful that the
Sharia is in such a way where your
opinions or like not I'm not talking
about you just anyone's opinions they're
coming I feel like this is coming I
don't care about your feelings I don't
care about your feelings I know where
you're coming from and it's and the
times we're living in where women have
so much power they are destroyed I'm not
saying he should have forced her to take
his buttons but is it wrong because if I
know she's putting argument's sake here
I would say my duty opponent is what I
have to pay for these bills I have to do
all of this I will give you arguments
saying this is how much I can afford a
week 50 pound 60 or whatever it may be
I'm gonna carry on doing that you're
putting against me this is what I'm
saying this is what I'll say is this
it's very simple in this instance here
the brother's regret was I wish that I
made her contribute towards the house or
that she didn't work at all no no no
because you're not working the 200 let
me first let me finish because the
brother now he's nearly 60 years old
yeah he had to give up the house to her
but he was that he bought himself
because the government gave it to her
yeah and he has to rebuild his life as
an old man here's the thing it's that
either you're paying this is the
conversation you can have either you're
paying towards the bills or you're
staying at home me personally you're
just staying at home but if you want
that the gentleman you want you want to
entertain this discussion and you know
whatever fine no problem but you're
gonna be paying baby because you're
taking value away from me that's that's
that's fine that's fine the one thing I
just want to say is this year 100 you're
right if the husband says that you
should I don't want you to work 100 but
there cannot be a violation of her
rights even though if she's plotting
against you it's it's this is given even
if she is because you know what that
means like at the end of the day I'll be
honest with you yeah like if somebody to
talk like this I don't know 30 grand
give someone 30 grand debt and he's not
paying you and I'll be honest with you
bro that was my family's savings Etc but
while he somebody and I'm not trying to
sound like Empires here but we're like
under their judgment Prof you owe me 30
grand the process of selling refused to
bury do the janazo of somebody who who
owed the debt to someone and the other
guy said you know I'll pay his debt and
he came after a certain amount of time
and said I have found him pay his debt
you know what the process said now his
skin is
um away from the fire or something along
those lines when he paid it eventually
so the consequences again goes to tawako
does this thing we should entire come
out of course retired come on should be
according to the Sharia this is simple
okay
the reality is and when we have these
conversations we should make the
conversation tailored to the masses the
masses yes require at least one and a
half income if you're living in London
you need 10 incomes Bob to run a house
yeah do you understand yeah especially
now so that's that's the
that the husband has a full right to
tell her wife not to work but the topic
at hand again is
um
so if if
it's a 50 50 situation you would be okay
with washing the dishes like because you
know what it is we just went because I'm
just trying to understand that if I am
working full-time yeah and my wife my
wife is working full-time yeah it's not
unreasonable for her to ask me Habibi do
you mind helping me out in the house if
she is working full time and she said to
you please can you help me I'm tied up
not even if she's working or she's not
working if she's work if she is working
yeah
she's not working and you know she's
tied up she's done Lots that's the
question that's the question
of course and she's like can you please
help me yes of course I'll do the dishes
by the way you got the rent this week
you're taking the meat okay okay okay
look look why do men go into marriage
okay in their wives okay
I'll tell you why I'll treat my wife
like a princess
in your wife as a princess I've asked my
husband
I will do the dishes
shopping's on you he taxes me okay
but the thing is just just to get back
to the topic here the question here is
because you you said hating your wives
that's a big statement the assistant may
Allah bless you yeah I know you do a lot
of contribution but the thing is the
fingers this year
yeah please elaborate just yeah because
when you say the word hater you've got
these sisters like yeah my husband must
hate me please just elaborate what you
mean I mean yeah
if you go into a relationship with this
you know kind of contentment like my
money and my she has to offer me value
it can come across as hate or it can
come across as a unfair unbalanced
situation you're not flowing in life
business for him I said business
contract yeah yeah that's exactly what
it is here exactly here's the thing yeah
if you mentioned you mentioned an issue
with the word value like you have to get
value do you know what the opposite of
value is Sister yeah valueless
if you're offering value look you know
especially men understand this as well
as a man
I find it an honor to be used by other
men if I can be used it means by
extension I am useful if I can't be used
I'm useless so if you are offering value
it's because you are valuable okay do
you see you can use it as a negative
connotation because I know what you're
saying used because he has a negative
connotation can we change that with
something because it'll be more
palatable because when we say used it's
like degrading it's not what you're
trying to say I want to be used because
it means I'm useful the word has
negative connotation this person used me
yes it's not you know what it is
sometimes this is yeah
you know what it is he speaks so much
Huck but the deliveries sometimes it's
so bad and this is why shakalbani said
for people to accept the hack is hard
don't make it worse with your bad and
I'm not talking about anybody don't make
it by using specific words and I'm not
you're not saying intentionally but if
there's another word you know what the
prophet means I'm just trying to a
personal advantage of him and those
who's watching when he means used means
that he's resourceful should they remain
resourceful maybe well I use the word
use very very specifically because use
ties into useful yes and useless on the
other end of the spectrum as well yeah I
understand what you're saying that's
what you mean yeah okay that's it so
don't see this it's this bad or why do I
have to get value it means
when my wife gives me value as a woman
we are invaluable
let's go especially when you're married
for me personally my husband earns very
well from home full time I'm on
maternity uh right now however we both
work from home we work out together we
are in a relationship we we do things
together sometimes the baby's screaming
crying he will help me and I think that
is good and good adab from his side and
good upbringing it doesn't mean oh this
week he I have to pay the rent he takes
care of everything but we work together
we're like friends
here I agree with you if if let's say
that something needs to be done in the
house alas if I want to do it I'll do it
the problem arises when it becomes an
expectation maybe it's Tuesday 3 P.M why
haven't you done the dishes okay this is
the issue but I don't think if I say
expectation on nasiva no no okay
no problem sister I agree with you I
should not have the expectation on you
and you should not have the expectation
on me to pay the landlord at the end of
the month
is he right or wrong okay hold on we're
going to be homeless our New Jersey is
placed upon you from Allah yes my duty
no no no because in Islam as a woman we
have rights and if you want your house
clean hire me a mate okay realistically
yes yes
sister this was in the context I'm sorry
one second yeah let's rewind a bit Yeah
the man is a full-time security guard
when a when a feat breaks in the house
best believe the other one's gonna
waking up faster than waking up for Fajr
yeah you're going to tell him you're
going to tell him listen I'm hearing
some mad noises downstairs you better
bounce and do something about it he's
going to be going to to find where it
may be yeah another example I gave is
when you're walking down the road next
time I come to start saying something to
you best believe if that guy AI here's
that and walks away you're going to lose
all respect for him but if he comes and
Sparks that guy in the face yeah he's
your protector number number three
earning you know what's very interesting
yeah sometimes when this means happened
between mother and father you see the
kids inclined into the mother a lot yeah
you know why because they can visually
see what the mother's doing in the house
look at my mom she's here she's there
she's looking after us well why if you
guys have a CCTV camera and saw that Dad
sweating picking up those bags of
whatever maybe he's carrying his back
breaking while lie then we would
understand what our fathers do so the
thing is now he's a protector he's a
provider yeah and not only that and
another thing I want to say is do you
guys do you guys have sons yeah okay you
know what I find the interesting
psychological as well yeah when you're
talking about these kind of things think
about your son so when you're saying any
time but this just think about your son
and be like
everything you said I disagree with
please tell me I'll tell you what I
agree with sister Amino yeah she said
that you should marry them that you
should hire a mate if you want me to
clean I agree I'll hire the maid and
I'll marry the
maids
I agree I'll hire her marry her okay
it's interesting but you see that was
interesting because you know why people
like yeah the first first first they
were like especially sisters watching
this yeah yeah Breeze Matthew comes in
yeah and then after my job second wife
oh one brother Matthew as well yeah but
anyways
you want to add on because you guys been
decided and I want to hear something
please
would you help your wife of course I
would okay yeah of course I would I'll
clean up you didn't touch up on the
point that we made as well yeah because
you mentioned oh that's a protector
provider security guard the guys put his
life on the line look what's happening
in Ukraine there's a war happening here
all these people even the ones that are
trans they're like no no I'm I'm I'm
fully yeah what was you born as okay
you're staying so you see that when
things go Peak the men are on the front
lines and these feminist women they say
you know what we missed the kitchen now
brother the kitchen was in banging place
to be yeah I made Biryani all day every
day so you see we live in a situation
where things are so calm that you can
have look female police officers I'm so
sorry man I saw one female police
officer chasing a guy well I didn't know
if she was dancing or she was running
yeah bro well like I was like this is
unbelievable and obviously I don't want
to get canceled but I'm saying it can't
be a police officer you guess what I'm
saying yeah the point is this bro come
on bro there was one guy he's a general
American Soldier he said we had to take
a woman off the battlefield she was
causing Brothers like men to die to come
and do the phone calls or whatever you
want to do yeah because she was causing
now this is a reality so what we're
saying is sister is that a man is doing
what and it's belittled and I want to
add something I agree on that something
I just want to add something here and
this is controversial about what lies
the heart if you had a job opportunity
and the job opportunity was the
following there is somebody hiring and
he wants you to make coffee and tea or
you have to cook him lunch at this time
and do the paperwork and whatever it may
be he's your boss and he says 55 pounds
for 10 minutes for an hour forget an
hour 55 minutes for every 10 minutes 550
pounds or whatever it may be an hour
you'll be running to that job you'll be
like and this is where I don't
understand yeah that when when you're
being paid you're like Biryani man's
Gonna Make You bloody like what do you
want to call it what's the best dish is
it away from what's the best dish there
okay okay
yeah let me tell you something sisters
will be cooking the most banging food
everything's on time tea coffee and then
the thing is this the same man just
think about it that boss he doesn't care
about you he pays you he can replace you
instantly your husband is willing to die
for you and he is willing to do that why
don't we be like be like hold on a
second this guy's paying for the rent
for the pill for the bill Etc whatever
it may be and why do we not see our
husbands like that but the moment if
it's a boss the sister like yeah of
course for 550 pounds no no I'm sorry no
I agree with my sister here we should
hire themes
you're talking about let me tell you
fire fire hire this one fire that one
yeah and this one's gonna do she's not
only gonna make the food she's actually
gonna be a wife as well
I agree
let's see what you're saying I
personally I love to cook I do
everything with happiness I do
everything alhamdulillah please but
honestly for the rebuttal of mehdi yeah
I had to make those points okay but the
point the point that I made do you
understand that you're making yeah of
course I I completely agree I believe
that the blessings that Allah is giving
me is way more than any pay or any of
that you know at least we're in a
partnership you're talking about your
husband by the way yeah yes yes of
course yes and I see how hard he works
and as women we shouldn't we should
learn to do these things and I do see
why marriages are failing when women
cannot do these things they cannot cook
they cannot clean they cannot raise
children and I think that parents should
if your daughter is lazy and you know
she is lazy that should be open
discussion you have to tell the man that
is going to marry her because it's a
very big problem in marriages you know
some women don't even change the sheets
of the bed after two weeks and this is
this is really disgusting Behavior so so
of course I do agree however I do think
you should have rahma and mercy upon
your life
sister
listen listen there was a post that you
did early on yeah which I like really
disagree with you about the thing like
for example you want to talk about it
that's one of the reasons I invite you
because I want to understand you better
yeah I don't think you come from a
malicious place but I genuinely want to
understand you better when it was about
your wife giving birth yeah and you did
and you did clarify you did say that
because there might be people new people
okay clarified so number one and that's
one of the reasons I brought here
because at the end of the day I don't
believe you have evil intent yeah so it
was about your your wife was giving
birth you you tell me what was it that
happened yeah so my wife went into labor
yes
you got this yeah called the ambulance
they were on their way yeah make sure
the door was open and said I'm off to
bed not just that yeah not just that
yeah I'll put you know on the new iPhone
on 13 onwards you can put the White
Noise yeah I put the ocean wave thing on
above so that I'm not disturbed because
it was early in the morning okay like
next to my ear do you understand yeah a
couple hours later we've got a baby okay
one second okay just let's just go into
it because
people's minds about yourself and it's
not nice I don't want you to do on
purpose what is the context because you
might think your wife is about to give
birth and you tend to go upstairs babe
contacts all of you they'll be like Oh
okay that's what we want our key we
don't look
we don't ever want to think don't let us
know
as a principal yeah it's not the place
for a man to be with a woman in the
labor world this is not the place I
agree and disagree I agree it's not a
man's place you know this is even in in
England this is a new thing bro go and
watch period pieces period movie pieces
do you know what the men would do just
from post-world War World War One 1925
onwards you know what men would do when
his wife goes into labor they go to the
pub they go to the pub bro and they
drink beer until the baby is born
explain why so people understand I know
where you're coming from that's why
that's the point I'm agreeing with women
are better
uh helping other laboring women hence
why most midwives are women in the first
place good that's Point number one point
number two you mentioned something which
I agreed with which is that you that's
obviously
um we're having a mature discussion here
I have my husband see me in that way
okay good good which was good good
sister famous mentioned it so basically
number two is that obviously a man that
he's intimate and if he sees certain
stuff that might put him off which I was
like very valid However if those things
are
fixed in the way where he doesn't need
to see it yeah all you have to do is go
behind the video it's simple because my
wife gave birth I was right behind her
which I'm trying to say and I'm not
saying like it was something that I
wanted to do and I'm not just saying
this I'm not someone just like hey yeah
give me a brownie Point genuinely I
wanted to be there genuinely well why if
I'm saying this but but the point I'm
seeing is and I I understand it was from
a point of view where I didn't see nine
you know the first part was the first
time that's where I disagree with and
the two points that you mentioned I
agree with I've had a lot of children
alhamdulillah so some of them I've been
there for some of them haven't been
there for so you have been there
I've had kids since I was 17 years old
bro okay but so you're saying that
you've learned a lesson to better not to
be from experience is that what you're
saying listen first time I walked into
have you seen Saul the movie Saw first
time I went into her labor board
you walk past doors yeah
and the noise it go it Peaks and it
fades ah F this what the hell is this
anyway anyway
I've noticed in my experience with a
laboring woman is that I'm like a just
like what what do I do I'm awkward and
and this is and then the Midwife comes
in it's also natural and these women are
just so much better right okay there's
some so much better I do learn a lesson
in life from it though let me be honest
yeah the respect that you have for your
mother when you witness this
you can never match that like just
watching your spouse the woman that you
love who's risk in her life I mean to me
to me it was like look when I look this
let me be honest when I first came to
Islam there was I'm a human being the
sins I would commit there was two sins
that I stopped by just by going burying
to people that I knew yeah that moment I
said and another perspective is when you
see your wife giving birth yeah it's
it's just not just your wife like to me
when I looked I was like what an amazing
creation Allah is created in a woman
yeah it's it's amazing that's why Allah
like he talks about we've given them two
eyes
um one mouth two lips and one tongue
yeah and Abdullah actually says that
this is that Allah
enabled the the child
Allah and we've showed them the two ways
which two ways is the you know the
mother suckling so the baby is aware and
knows isn't it interesting like when the
baby's born he knows exactly what to do
so to me it was a reflection point of
wow man this is this is a really an
amazing things it just really
um makes you think it makes you Ponder
so from that perspective I totally
understand and that's why I agree with
you and disagree with you but now you've
seen it directly would you watch it
again no no but the thing is I never
watched it that's what I'm saying bro so
I'm saying from a certain perspective
you didn't see it you don't know because
you know why but when you're behind the
bed yeah when you're behind the bed okay
there's a certain angle bro you don't
see nothing and let me be honest on
purpose I don't want to see nine yeah
foreign
I had nothing to lose now is it a must
if my wife's if my wife came and said
you must be there the question I ask is
why do you say must if they say think of
oh feminist I'm not coming just because
you bought the whole feminist I'm not
coming you know why because if you're
going to measure our Dynamics and our
marriage success based on some
feministic Ideology Now I'm not coming
but if it's like you know what I would
like you to be there I would say this if
as a man it doesn't impactment affect me
I'll be there if it does I'll tell her
no and guess what if I told her the
reason she'll tell me don't come okay
bro I'm just saying the clarification
which was in the hospital but not in the
house you didn't give the house we need
it because we want people to assume the
best okay now I just want to understand
from from brother to brother yeah yeah
because I wasn't you wiggled your way
out of this one yeah
I would say the first time I went for
example it was an experience for me it
was like so much things um I learned
from it but why do I can I say I'm gonna
go back again for the same experience
I've really experienced it so if I was
to say for example that do you need me
there for what yeah so if she comes and
says no but I need you because you know
if you really care hold on a second so
me carrying this because of this
specific moment that I have to be there
I would say that's problematic I would
come if I want to come yeah and of
course in that situation for example if
we're at home and she's I'm not gonna be
like like for example what you said I
wouldn't do like okay you go nah my
wife's in labor I can't tell the Year
boss baby and then put a I personally I
would say now that's that's a bit
merciless personally me I would say that
can I just have you seen the sunset
books have you seen the sunset before
you said the Midwife came
so viewers that are watching yeah the
Midwife came so you didn't want to be
there he mentioned the impression people
should assume the best I think the
impression people got is basically my
wife went into labor yeah and all hell
broke loose yes and I just bounced and I
just bust that's your fault bro that's
your fault you put it like that I'll
show you Instagram you ought to blame
bro he was broke he was like yeah my
wife went into labor
thing put the fingers so
firstly and foremostly my wife is used
to having quick births so quick in fact
that one time we went when we went to
the hospital
the baby was coming out on our way on
her way there because I wasn't allowed
to meet her and then when she got to the
hospital she gave birth in the hallway
she couldn't make it to the to the room
baby she's like she grabbed the whole
the Midwife said I can't that's it it's
coming that's it and it came out then
and there right after that she said I've
never gone to the hospital again forget
that I'm having babies at home
so then
after that since we had two more at home
alhamdulillah quick happens no problem
quickly alhamdulillah when she went into
labor called the ambulance you're on
your way fantastic open the door make
sure the door was open girls are
upstairs told them this in girls your
mom's going into labor now you know if
she needs you anything like this she
probably won't but just keep your ears
out I'm off to bed mate so then I had
taken care of everything the door was
open and he came I actually went to bed
when a in the paramedics arrived not
paramedics this because you have to
arrange this stuff in advance so why did
you not say that on your post because
it's so long bro but come on bro you
know you don't know but you can be
blameworthy of people having a negative
assumption about you on purpose and
you're doing it on purpose which is not
correct Islamic people because even even
now no no no no no no no no no but still
bro
still bro the thing is this stuff
because you know what you've done you've
made like like this is why look I'm be
honest this is the reason I was double
minded about inviting you let me be very
honest here we're mentally okay look I I
have nothing against um everyone should
be by the way yeah no no I have nothing
personally against you which again I'm
trying to say I've watched some of the
stuff
um like you know you said and there's
certain things where I thought you know
what this guy is not as evil as people
make him out to be so that's what I
thought look I want to understand him
better so that's why I invited you here
and look the clarification you gave
that's how it was when I wrote the post
I think I have uh a bit of a um
how can I say an extremist Ben in my
character in terms of my delivery even
the way I apply myself to work yes to
anything I apply myself to is in the
extreme and the way that I talk and and
negotiate and everything is on the
extreme so when I wrote that post it
come that came out naturally it wasn't
strategic to be honest I just put it out
like blah there you go post I wasn't
expecting it to go viral regret it of
course not
could it have been worded a bit better
because could I have given more context
yeah of course I could have given more
context yeah because you know why like
like I said before the reason I'm doing
abroads I don't want people to think bad
of you because I don't think you're an
evil like I don't think I know there was
those things that you've done because I
can remember I've done a podcast with
your job and I I referenced you and I
said this is a value it's oppression
like yeah I believe yeah because and I
stuck by that because but now when I
remember you've done a podcast with
Dilly when you gave some context and I
was like yeah why did you not say that
I'm trying to say as a Believer I didn't
want to think that of you alhamdulillah
that's the reason I brought you here
because yeah I just I just put it out
like that to be honest you know
sometimes I do word things in a
particular way to be for maximum effect
that wasn't one of them that was just
boom there you go and I believe that by
the way now maybe you could say you want
to experience it for the first time yeah
and you're seeing your child born I've
never looked by the way everyone never
want to either but being in a vicinity
being there you know your child's born
first time I get that it's it's an
amazing thing after that above I'm out
I'm going to the Halal Pub you know what
I just remembered as well because I can
remember my wife was giving birth she
was actually saying to her mom to tell
me tell him to go out because she was
like I don't want him to see me like
this yeah so that's why yeah you need to
understand that's why I agree with the
stuff that you said people just like no
I'm so sorry there's valid points here
so it was a nice balance but going back
to hustle Jones
um would you expect your partners to do
the hoovering dishwashing or whatever it
may be and imagine and put yourself in a
perspective world like Matthew said is
that they are the provider The Sole
Provider you don't have
um sort of say that to me I'm me I'm
quite old school don't you know but I do
seem s points I personally don't find it
attractive to see a man doing certain
things like that and I think one to one
we can you know negotiate and he's got a
heart he had a you know who I was with
who would automatically know if I was
tired and would help out with the
children with whatever but most innocent
families you know at the end of the day
it's usually the women that would just
automatically whether it's segregation
in talking even when we went together or
even helping out in the kitchen all the
women are together not that it's our job
but this is how we brought up and I
don't like it when women are like well
they have to do this and they have to
I'm like well I don't know it just
doesn't feel attractive and masculine to
me and especially what I see a man in
front of everyone especially you know
trying to do all of this because I'm
raising voice too I want them to learn
it as a skill so that if they need to
they should know how for themselves and
to help their future wives but not for
them to be taken advantage of and they
also have to play their role okay you
know what a little sister that's what I
say don't take advantage from
females in the perspective of then they
don't usually hide that no we like it we
like them saying no you're brutally
honest and that's the reality and this
is one of the reason we started the show
understand us better look she just spoke
from her fitra we don't like seeing that
this doesn't mean that husband can't
come here and there yeah Etc and I said
this before once my wife cooked roast
Etc invited my mom my brother Etc came
and I saw she was exhausted like this
time I said you know what I'm going I'll
wash dishes I not you're telling me she
didn't come and say to me well afternoon
I said you know what I want to yeah and
I I remember my mom's like Mama was very
specific no no I'll do it I said mum I
want to do it nobody's telling me to do
it I'm trying to say but the point is
about demanding expecting and coming
from the individual yeah sister Ira
please you've been quiet is there
anything that you like I just wanna
please if you face anything the same
agree with what our sisters have said
and I think um there's nothing wrong
with helping of course I think marriage
when you get married that's you're
signing up for a full-time job right you
have your job where you go out and you
earn your money Etc but when you come
home that's also a job
and it's wrong for you to come home and
I guess have that expectation that
everything was will be served to you and
you ain't lift a finger because we all
have our off days there's days where you
know the husband can have more energy
and maybe the wife doesn't so it's using
your own initiative
um to step in and chip in when you can
it shouldn't be demanded and I think the
biggest problem that we face is
the way that we are asking of our
partners to help out I think women can
be really demand for and I think the way
they're learning it is very incorrect
they'll almost like blackmail you or
emotionally blackmail in a way like you
know you don't care you don't love me
have you not seen how much work I've
been doing I've been doing this looking
after kids what have you done
and I think when you start to be little
a man
he will start to lose respect for you
and vice versa
um and then obviously that causes all on
problems later on in life but I think
it's as I said a marriage is is a job
you both need to chip in when you can
you need to work together as a team just
as you would if you were in the office
or you know doing your own business I
also just quickly want to say though on
the other hand there are certain
communities and cultures that do take
advantage over women as well so there is
that culture that background that sort
of you know South Asian sort of side of
things where whether she's working or
not whether she's at home or not
whatever they do tend to just think that
the woman is just only there for the
house and that's it and they do not
contribute even if the wife like you
mentioned both are working and earning
it's just solely on her and I see this a
lot a lot you know amongst my clients
which I've recently seen the South Asian
background where it's just her job
solely and if she you know is tired or
whatever she's literally like the slave
and I do want to also highlight that for
some of those women who are going
through it but generally me I want to
basically serve and I want a man to be a
man and I want them to actually you know
be able to do what they do and me do
what I do and at one point I can do and
manage all of it so I think more women
should be raised to be able to do that
and I find it really attractive if a man
is the audience are saying a different
side I think that's a very refreshing
take actually yeah and I would actually
say that unfortunately I think that
modern Western society and feminism
would actually try to shame you for what
you've just said just right there for
sure you know what I mean you'd be
feminist but just because I have a voice
but actually they don't understand my
contacts either I mean they're trying to
call you a bad guy and I think what's
happening a lot as well is that I think
a lot of women are actually just like
you I think they are inclined and they
do want to serve they do want a big
strong man to put them in their place
say all right love not go do the dishes
boom boom boom you're my little princess
I don't think any husband that I know
tells their wife go do the dishes yeah
I'm I'm kind of just putting it plainly
right now to be very honest with you
and I think a lot of girls do want a man
to be in control to put them in their
place to be that type of character that
they can look up to like oh wow but
they're being shamed for it by other
um ideologies that aren't our own
ideologies and I think it all goes back
to following the corner of the sunlight
at the end of the day that's the perfect
way and the only right way you know I
mean is there anyone I don't know you've
been silent but if there is they don't
know do you know what it is it might
sound quite degraded in rudia but it's
like I think about it
how come you never asked I'm gonna say
something
every time
listen yeah
yeah
um it's not that I don't mean it like I
mean until everybody like these are
issues that I just don't respectfully
see myself
what do you mean you don't see yourself
having what do you mean by that like
exceptional
I just can't see myself debating the
woman that I have met and I've now
married her and we're sitting down in
the house after I've worked my ass off
to be maybe the man that I'm I am in the
future and she's and I'm debating this
woman can you please please
it's just something I wouldn't debate
about it
it's like it just goes without saying
you're saying but you know it's like her
asking like he does these are over it's
like her asking I know those things like
people during cmn those days are dude
yeah
the majority then bro and it might sound
arrogant no no no no no no
he's not willing to be the majority you
didn't tell the secret to their brothers
who are watching because that's that's
about my course
no but um yeah honestly I don't I know
it might come across arrogant and I
promise you I don't mean it with any
arrogance it's just like I'm not going
to start talking about something like
and get really passionate just stop
passionate about this stuff is like
it's like for me it's like um it's like
a woman coming to me and saying like you
said earlier like she oh like you know
you've got to protect me if a man calls
me a name on the street exactly exactly
offended if I even saying that exactly
your fingers bro this is so disgusting
today bro this is the reality we're
dealing with what you're saying is it
it's it's a no-brainer
with no brains that's the thing there's
no brains left to be a no-brainer
Traditions are failing at you know what
I said
it's bad and like um
the other thing I I feel like people are
doing they just like
everyone's just a sheep everyone's a
bunch of sheep now so it'll be like one
woman
scared as well yeah but you play my
problem because if I if I sit here now
and I start saying but do you blame us
for being scared because the moment we
start like voice in our opinions
we get called really bad uh titles that
are like like lowly titles so um that's
why sometimes I just don't say anything
even though I know it might seem like
well why don't you just say because I
can't be bothered to have yeah a title
that is going to block me from getting
certain blessings later on and it's not
even a true title you know what I'm
saying but my thing is again
um like I've grown up mostly with women
so I respect women highly my sisters 12
years older than me
um my mum's well almost like she had me
when she was 30.
um so I've always had like a lot of
females around me and I respect them
heavily so
again just sitting down and feeling like
if I found a woman and I have to ask her
like you know you gotta Tidy Up by the
way you know you've got a Hoover by the
way and you've got like it just doesn't
go yeah for me for me but I I'm not
gonna lie if you are a guy at home
I promise you I'm not saying that of any
form of arrogance whatsoever but I
genuinely feel sorry for men that have
to debate these things and catch up into
an argument with your with your wife
over simple things and just for the
record I would happen I happily would
cling and tired and do this I'll happily
do it but it's not a thing where I I'll
do it because she I feel like I'm forced
to do but you know what that I totally
agree with you that's big facts if
you're in that position where you're a
man if the debate with your wife oh can
you do the dishes please love like yes
longer but unfortunately and like I
laughed initially when I thought to
myself actually you know what there are
loads and that's what I have to say
I'll tell you why not yes why do you
feel like cool one thing I wanted to say
is like because they are scared they
will they will they can lose the house
they can lose the kids they can be
accused abuse they can be accused of
rape look at that topic we just covered
my brother I'll tell you what I tell you
I was telling like this off camera and
you last year I said listen Bros like
I'm not getting married in this country
there is two ways I'm dual spicier but
I'm never getting married in this
country again yeah luckily I was broke
then when I got a divorce here I'm in a
position where I've got something to
lose yeah and I realized how irrational
sometimes things can be in those
situations yeah and I said look these
are the two occasions in which I'm
getting married yeah I said I'm moving
to Dubai maybe in a year or so yeah or a
Muslim country where the law is a bit
more like Sharia compliance a bit more
Islamic law towards that side or
alternatively straight up yeah I'm
moving to Morocco yeah I'm gonna go into
a village in Morocco I'm marrying two
three girls I'm changing their lives I'm
gonna get them nice houses everything
you know I'm eating a nice cheap part of
Morocco live on the beach yeah make sure
they can live on make sure they know
Quran they can teach my kids Quran
alhamdulillah I want to work remote from
Morocco on a beach
let me tell you the downfall yeah
if they asked me to come oh can you
bring us to like no you can't come to
London with Sam Morocco in the village
you're not coming it's not good there
don't worry about that love yeah
yeah
one second are you Pakistan where are
you from
um I'm half Iranian and half mauritian
okay so I'm seeing this new phenomenon
of Pakistani Asian men going to Morocco
to get married yeah I'm seeing a
phenomenon I'm speaking to Bear people
okay Moroccan what's going on Brooke
Morocco everyone's going Morocco yeah
and bro it works I know a lot of
brothers who have married successfully
but here's some mad horror stories yeah
so this is why sometimes Village girls
sometimes Village girls bro when they
come to the West bro boom bro just be
careful
man please like I do see this phenomenon
yeah stop fetishizing Moroccan why are
they doing it
it's a bit like I'm not gonna lie it is
a bit um you know it hurts my feelings
I'm not gonna lie the fetishization you
don't go to Morocco and just think I'm
gonna go for Moroccan women just because
they are these so-called good girls and
they're whatever and they're gonna be so
so submissive and whatever like be
careful like don't you I just want to be
clear yeah because I'm not fetishizing
uh when I first came up with this plan
yeah this master planner man yeah I was
actually planning going south of
Thailand because I think the king lets
the Muslims that live there rule under
like Sharia law and things like I need
to fact check that but that's what I've
heard there's like a large community of
Muslims in the south of Thailand and
they're allowed to kind of like govern
their own marriages and things like that
as long as you're not murdering no one
then they might get involved so my
original plan was Thailand and then
somebody suggested why don't you go
Morocco Algeria because they know Arabic
they can teach your kids Quran and it's
closer to London I was like yeah boom
dust patterns you know my brother you
know what let me let's show you so
they're going to get them out for five
minutes so let me tell you something man
and this is all jobs aside yeah
what the plan you had is not a master
it's a master plan of many men right now
yeah yeah dogs Society
um the reason why I'm saying this is
because I feel like I'm that I'm that in
between the guy of
very very naughty kind of people and
very very good people overall Muslims
right
so I hear
foreign
the best and the worst in both worlds
majority of men even the good good
brothers that I know and the bad bad
brothers are not are tired bro so this
plan of just getting away and finding
this Safe Haven is happening throughout
so then
any man will think right
I want to come closer to my Dean as I'm
getting older yeah we all see the signs
of Yama kelma coming to us now so a lot
of men even the bad boys I know that are
Muslim I like you know what I need to
get closer to my Dean I need to stop
doing what I'm doing I need to go find
me a good Muslim woman the Muslim women
in the west I'm even absolutely mad
overall not all there's some very good
gems still there yeah so I think right
this might be my type this might be my
type and they do go to one place with
Moroccan Algeria has had one and the
other one was um
it was another place
[Music]
yeah because they just said like it's
the same thing that the sister said
because there's this stereotype whether
it's true or not I don't really I'm not
going to get into it is that it's like a
everything that we kind of want in a
woman like they're submissive they're
gentle they beautify themselves they're
loyal they're good family and the Arabic
tongue because we most of us men want
our children to be like halfers of Quran
by a certain age and stay away from my
life that we got very much tempted to a
street or road life
so
right now what I again what I'm seeing
is
sisters that are living in the west that
are saying all these demands like my man
needs to have this he needs to buy me
this this marks for the macrame I might
not even sleep with him on the first
night all of these from acting they
don't understand that they're actually
making things 10 times worse for
themselves and again
um sister said the sister said um that
we should not fit a size over these
things yet it's very true we shouldn't
you know however there's something that
is
not the seed to make us want to find
this Escape group somewhere and that is
because the women here that wait that we
aims to marry are making it so hard for
us if it was made easier for us or we
had something kind of to look forward to
here we wouldn't have to run somewhere
else which is now seeming like uh
one more time
this is another topic on itself please
last me on Tuesday is but to be very
honest with you bro I don't even fully
blame the girls you know what I mean for
what they're saying and things like that
yeah and the reason I don't fully blame
the girls I think it's in their nature
to not be as clear-headed as maybe we
are and more logical we are so I think
it I think a lot of them do go into
these situations with very good
intentions bro I like that one just we
just watched the other bit of Truth uh
podcast here when it comes to divorce
time yeah when things get real yeah they
may have had best intentions whatever
whatever these law is
Brothers it was amazing and I hope you
guys benefited as well if you want to be
a part of the panel get a contact from
an email if you want us to ask us a
question or go through something that's
openly married please let us know our
next topic is going to be C for second
wives and we'll see you in that one
inshallah uh